Every black hole of the same mass and they also have a spin
is
according to Einstein according to their equations exactly the same and
this puzzled people and
The great John Wheeler who also invented the word black hole
Described this by saying a black hole has no hair. That is it's a featureless
object so if you have two
bald people in the room you can't
Distinguish them by their hairdos. If you do people with hair you can say what has a short haircut. The other one has a comb-over
Whatever, there's many different distinguishing features. So stars are like
People with hundred black holes or like bold people. They're all the same
and well if you can't see very well, so
He envisioned if you say threw a
cup of tea
I think it's the the metaphor that he is you take a cup of tea and you sort of throw it into a black hole
He was worried that the the information
Carried by the tea the entropy if he will the disorder care about the tea would have no way of showing up
Inside the black hole because like you say it has no hair and they all look the same, right?
so this system was a
puzzle that you could sort of get rid of entropy by throwing it inside a black hole and it would be gone from
the universe and his student
Bekenstein began to think about this and he gave insights that ultimately led to your work
What was his view of this puzzle? Well, they were very bothered so
going back to Newton and before
there is an idea which is very important to physicists namely that there are laws of physics and
Moreover we like to think that the laws of physics govern
everything that happens if we knew all of them and if we had perfect knowledge
and part of that is that
information should never be lost things can't just disappear and
So if you threw a cup of coffee or a computer or your diary or something into a black hole?
according to the way that Einstein would have
Described them
There's no trace of it left. It's just vanished and that is
antithetical to everything that
Physicists would like to believe